a mass grave for what Ukraine has called
a massacre
Russian troops accused of killing
civilians before pulling out of this
town close to Kiev
no hiding the horror
unclear how many bodies are lying in
this makeshift resting place
More Hell in the basement of a house in
butcher
Ukraine's military says Russian forces
used it as a torture chamber victims
allegedly had their hands bound before
being shot
evidence of potential war crimes above
ground as well
the brother of keeves Mayor documented
what he saw
this is now Special Operation this is my
military objects this is civilians
they've been shot in the head with a
tight hands behind their back
there's a genocide of the Ukrainian
population
Ukraine says hundreds of bodies have
been found in this town and others
Northwest of the capital
it's accused Russia of being worse than
Islamic State though moscow's denied
responsibility
Horrors that have been left behind can
you talk about that the mass Graves is
that true are you seeing evidence of
civilians being killed in Buca in
Airplane yes I think it's uh new cases
for the Garg
international criminal court and I think
that will be a lot of evidence and we
will see new nurburg process uh probably
in butcher probably in European or in or
in mariopal it will be a lot of new
nurburg's process against the criminal
military criminal
who did it in our country the defense
minister was referring to the trials put
on for Nazi criminals after the second
world war as he spoke on a visit to a
nearby airport
troops rewarded for helping retake this
place hostile
it was a key Russian Target on day one
of the invasion and a major Battlefield
ever since until a couple of days ago
when Russian troops withdrew but no one
thinks it's over yet
oh she didn't
see them
I know a lot of a lot of struggles uh
before and
the younger
ah yeah and after and after
so
we have to prepare
to a future future struggles
it's hard to believe that this area
about 16 miles outside Kiev was a
popular commuter belt
then Russian forces heading for the
capital tried to push through only to be
met by Fierce Ukrainian resistance
Ukrainian forces bond this bridge as
part of their efforts to slow the
Russian Advance which didn't get much
Beyond this point they then used
artillery fire to smash a line of
Russian armored vehicles
the charred carcasses of at least six
Russian soldiers lie Frozen in Time
wrecked fighting Vehicles also litter
this road
standing here could have been a death
sentence just a few days ago now
Ukrainian forces move around freely
residents who chose not to flee also
venturing outdoors with Tales of Horror
one woman described what she'd said to a
Russian soldier who'd entered her home
foreign
the images of death from this town have
shocked a world already reeling from
Russia's War
each corpse a potential crime scene and
Ukraine says it wants Justice
Deborah Hayne Sky News butcher